allora ragazzi vi racconto una roba che
secondo me li farò le libere quando io
ho iniziato a fare video
ok quindi era il 2013 inizio 2013 era
molto molto molto complicato trovare
video giochi indie horror da fare voi
sapete che quel periodo erano esposti
tutti i videogiochi o ruby voglia
spiegare però una dinamica che non a
tutti era chiara insomma di quando ho
iniziato a fare video
siccome non era ancora il mio lavoro
youtube non avevo tutti questi soldi da
poter spendere in cui giochi purtroppo
non avevo e quindi dovevo per forza
cercare di arrangiarmi con quelli che
costavano poco tranne una volta
praticamente è uscito questo gioco sul
film che si chiama dementium ii ed era
un horror che dalle immagini sembrava
incredibile
allora detto no vabbè costa 20 euro che
erano tantissimi i tempi però ho detto
re lo prendo perché comunque lo porto ci
farò un sacco di video e quindi bella
vita era una merda quindi a distanza
oggi di otto anni da quando spesi quei
20 euro voglio portare sul canale
dementium ii hd già che c'è a cadine
dopo specificarlo nel nome oggi lo
portiamo indipendentemente dalla
bellezza del gioco lo portiamo guarda
che grafica charles di tatuaggi qua che
poi credo che effettivamente le menti
sia un abbastanza riconosciuto come oro
[Musica]
20 euro signori comunque non so se avevo
già da allora io ci ho giocato quei
diciotto diciannove minuti e gestito su
steam e poi l'ho abbandonato ovviamente
senza registrarlo quindi ho ripreso
esattamente da da quel punto lì quindi
non mi ricordo neanche i tasti se ci
devo se devo essere sincero però vabbè
fa niente
usali iniezione per incrementare
temporaneamente le funzioni motorie va
bene gli ormeggi gioco è ormai spesso di
20 euro
prima o poi a distanza di otto anni mi
sono ripromesso che li nel recupero si
sono quindi guardate le pubblicità e
cliccate le per favore cosa vedo cos'è
estense e o store
hanno avuto inizio la preparazione c'è
qualcosa di strano nella tua testa e noi
l'abbiamo fatto uscire non c'è qualcosa
di strano nel corso di questo gioco
frate non è una testa fina di krasic no
mai se ne ignora la mia parte sana non
la vedo se fosse scelto sharon rovente
che ba iberia
quello che questo continua liberamente
nella loro lasciata dal loro pianto sul
mio portafoglio e la ora abbiamo una
boss fight ragazzi sembra in discoteca
trovata questa luce o doppi chiare
secondo me lui che picchia me raga ho
solo un coltello come potrei far fuori
questo qui sono bravissimo sono fenomeno
sono fortissimo sto battendo un gorilla
se non so neanche chi cacchio è ma
guarda così ho nostalgia del mio amico
che mi diceva fai cagare nell'altra
stanza
ok lo appunto
c'è un fenomeno bravissima 20 euro ben
spesi ritiro tutto frate ti do sto
coltello se mi dai 19 euro e 99 ora
eccola qua la revolver ce l'abbiamo
sul personale medico di sicurezza il pan
7 guidarello orengo e un codice giallo
sono io il paziente devo sparare le
porte per per sbloccarle ottimo aperto
da porca [ __ ] vi sono cagato nelle
mutande ma che su raiuno dico è uno di
quelli di wii happy few maori mori
perfetto bravissimo devo aperto da qua
no
amallah sopra dove lo prima york a vacca
questo disputa la cui prima si è
rialzato no un altro e mori porca vacca
quanti colpi altra gente
avete voglia di passarmi altre altre
munizioni parla revolver che gli faccio
saltare il cranio come se niente fosse
giorno stesse one to one free my brother
perfetto come morto male ma cos'è
ma cos'è che brutta roba no vabbè 22
sono già complicati da
da sfidare pam buono 2 perfetto a segno
con tutti i colpi lo zio fa vi prestiamo
da due là della roba dentro sti cosi
però non capirò mai come si apre led che
prevede una boss fight non so perchè ma
mi sa troppo di è troppo grosso come
posto per essere solo un posto di
passaggio aperto siamo fuori bellissimo
o madonna e gli occhi mi mi stanno
ringraziando la lettera perfetto
torniamo vivo nello schifo
le larve 12 hanfree let's go è una mazza
o posso spaccare le porte spacco le
porte a tutti quanti let's go
ecco c'è gente lo sapevo con c'è gente
qua c'è gente eccola dall arma rimasta
lì la prima nel anno la donnola cagone
anche pillole di salute va bene non vedo
niente tra l'altro il suo sì palomino
aumentare la luminosità non penso
12 è vamonos qua dentro le scale a
questa è la portata di prima
questa si apre no perché deve avere una
chiave secondo me è chiusa bene andiamo
a trovare la chiave è sempre divertente
comunque sparare col mio revolver starò
il salvataggio salute restaurato non
c'era bisogno perché ormai sono stato un
esperto mi scalfisce vi niente ora non
ho la minima idea di dove sto andando
francesco perché come cacchio faccia
semplice la torcia a man è diventato
slang mi sa che noi non lo posso colpire
ok questo nemico in colpibile va bene
andiamo avanti senza facendo finta che
non ci sia lo driblato in tutto questo è
inutile sprecare colpi su di lui di
senatore ex pia spetto patrol un dio
però so bravo a destreggiarmi destra
sinistra e poi la squadra di allegri ma
se il voto ma chi ti vuole
ma chi sei posso spaccare la porta posso
entrare lì non ci provo neanche giorno
meno non si può entrare ma spacco tutto
qua
let's go posso andare vado cellula speed
the run praticamente raga che schifo ma
cos'è sto ma che razza di tunnel ha
scavato quello ma cos'è la pubblicità
sì sì cerci credo tantissimo guarda non
si spacca neanche proprio neanche
neanche di la soddisfazione di spaccarsi
va bene anche air to shoot to the mostri
1 i doors i tre si 4612 rimasto un colpo
solo tra l'altro e l'ho mancato ottimo
la mazza che usa la mazza fun park a tra
viola mica sono thor che non sia in
amore la madonna soino quattro colpi di
mazza per fare un colpo della pistola
vede schifo fa schifo la marcia ragazze
condom era forse anche un cruccio a
porta attenzione e fico il gioco 20 euro
io non ci credo a norcia per due sono
uscito
ok raga riguarda posso concludere quale
episodio perché sono uscito l'importante
questo ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come al solito se il video è
piaciuto lascia il tuo commento mi piace
anche al fabi che aver speso dei soldi
ai denti per intrattenervi